and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn today we're gonna
talk about whether reducing our
consumption is enough to save the planet
or whether we need to do more than just
recycle share stuff and consume less
we're also going to talk about the
upsides and downsides of capitalism
we're going to talk about the potential
necessary changes that we need to make
to environmental policy and we're going
to talk about some misconceptions about
human progress and we're gonna do all
that with today's guest
I'm here with MIT scientist Andrew
McAfee Andy thanks for joining us today
hey thanks for having me on no relation
to John right I know I used to kind of
be upset about that and now I'm fairly
glad I don't think I share a lot of
genes with John McAfee I check in on his
Twitter account occasionally but it's
only for fun and because you know it's
like it's like watching a train wreck in
real time hopefully this will be
different experience well like me Andy
you are an optimist how is your your at
least from everything I can tell from
from your new book which will be talking
about your new book more from less and
you're definitely an optimist how is
this current pandemic that we're going
through challenging your optimism
yeah pandemics are not good times for
optimists right this is not the time to
be exploring all kinds of silver linings
or telling people to look on the bright
side we are fighting this really scary
implacable foe that via evolution has
figured out this you know devilish this
insidious strategy for getting from body
to body and is killing some of those
bodies in its wake I am NOT going to sit
here and try to put a happy face on a
pandemic yeah yeah although what I'll
say is and we're gonna get more into
your book and what I like about about
you is I don't know exactly where to
place you there's not a box I often feel
that that's quite a compliment thank you
well I mean I can't tell whether you're
a libertarian
or a progressive you're a liberal or
conservative you're capitalist or a
socialist a minimalist or a maximalist
that's actually that's the nicest thing
I've heard in a long time because very
often we just we label somebody as
something as a way of categorizing them
and dismissing them oh then you know
that guy's another frothing at the mouth
libertarian oh there's another
bleeding-heart liberal so if you find me
a little hard to pin down I think that's
that's fascinating and great news well
and I think the truth is that you are
none of these labels and all of them at
the same time there are ingredients from
each of these sort of recipes or
ideologies and we could talk about the
dangers behind certain ideology I think
that's fair yeah thank you yeah and so
this is a listener driven show but
before we dive into our audience's
questions would you please talk about a
little bit about what motivated you to
write more from less yeah so I am NOT an
environmental scientist and if you'd
asked me a few years ago if I was gonna
write about a book about the about the
environment and I'm the human
relationship with the planet Earth I
would have said you know no that that's
not in my sweet spot at all until I read
this amazing essay published I think in
2015 by this wonderful scientist named
Jessie aza Bell and he said hey year
after year in America we are now using
fewer molecules fewer resources less
tonnage of stuff to grow the overall
economy and he was clear he said look
this is not less tonnage per person per
American this is less stuff year after
year by all Americans put together and
I'm reading this I'm like oh this poor
guys mistaken right this is not how
growth works this is not how economies
grow we grow our population we grow our
economy thereby we grow our prosperity
we get well it wealthier in aggregate
over time but duh you need to take more
from the earth you need to take more
resources minerals metals fertilizer
water you need you need all these
molecules to grow an economy year after
a year and so I looked at the references
all jebel provided you wrote this lovely
essay really thorough references and I'm
like this guy is right and it was weird
for me because I study technological
progress and how technology changes
things and I didn't think I had that
nailed
but I kind of thought
I knew the drill and this
dematerialization was not part of my
understanding so getting on top of that
and then trying to extend Jesse's work
and some other work and figure out why
it was happening what's me what's the
story here and what does this imply for
things like growth and capitalism and a
relationship with the planet Earth it
just was a project that could not walk
away from we're gonna dive a lot more
into that I want to hop into some
voicemails from our audience real quick
our first question today is from Mariah
and Denver Colorado
I personally fall into minimalism a few
years ago after a cross-country bike
tour and I've been practicing my version
of minimalism through my highest value
of Environmental Conservation and zero
waste living I can tell you both care
for the environment to your podcast and
I would love to hear podcast dedicated
to environment and here you're taking
how to practice minimalism through this
one
so Andy it sounds to me like mariah is
asking this question about minimalism
let me explain to you when when when
Ryan and I talk about minimalism as the
minimalist sort of this this idea of a
lifestyle of thriving with less you know
the average American household has
somewhere around 300 thousand items in
it and while many of those are essential
some of them are non-essential and most
of them are actually junk and we like to
delineate between those three categories
essential items things we truly need
non-essential things are things that
probably add value to our life we get by
without them and so we do want them they
augment or enhance our experience of
life and then of course most of those
things are the junk the things we hold
onto just in case we might need them
someday and some non-existent
hypothetical future and so I didn't I
didn't stumble across minimalism as a as
a means to save the environment but I
think one of the beautiful one of the
beautiful side effects of this or the
byproducts of consuming less is of
course you produce less waste I
certainly still produce some waste I buy
some things that that add value to my
life and sometimes there's waste
involved in that but what I like about
your book Andy is you talk about how
technology and innovation is actually
allowing us
produce even less waste because we were
sort of the things that we have now
especially with respect to technology we
are we're using less materials to
produce those things than ever before
yeah and the central phenomenon of my
book of more from les is this big corner
that we've turned or this weird tipping
point that we reached where we can
continue to grow our populations and our
economies while taking less from the
earth fewer resources fewer minerals all
of that and that's not because all of
America suddenly decided to embrace
minimalism your podcast is not that
popular yeah we didn't turn our backs on
consumption and prosperity and you know
stuff we just haven't done that now I'm
a devotee of minimalism I hope that I
hope this mantra spreads because as you
just pointed out lots of our stuff
doesn't really do anything for us it
doesn't make us happy it doesn't add to
our lives great have less of that stuff
I think that's fantastic and that will
support the trend that's already
underway of being able to live our lives
and not have to feel like we're
suffering or going without and continue
to enhance prosperity around the world
while at the same time lightening our
footprint on the earth taking better
care of our planet there's this strong
intersection with my most recent work
with minimalism and with being good to
this earth that we all live on now
didn't I mean the only the only problem
I have right now when I think about this
is I do feel like overconsumption got us
here in the first place and it was
irresponsible of us we haven't been good
stewards of the resources that we have
are you saying that that innovation and
technology allows us to be better
stewards of those resources it
absolutely does it's not the whole story
but it's a critically important part of
the story and I just want to agree
violently with you that for a long time
we were not good stewards of the planet
that that we have sworn
all over and I'm intensely grateful
we're one day away as we record this
podcast from the 50th anniversary of
Earth Day
Earth Day happened on April 22 1970 for
the first time I am intensely grateful
to Earth Day and the modern
environmental movement that came out of
it because they grabbed our societies
and our governments and the business
sector by the lapels and shook them and
said we gotta stop this we are not being
good stewards of the earth and they said
a couple things that that were
incredibly important and profound one of
them was we have to stop polluting and
it's incredibly hard for us 50 years
later to go back to 1970 but the
consensus in a lot of places was hey man
pollution is a price we pay for economic
growth and prosperity and during debates
about the clean air clean air act one
member of Congress said there's a mare
in my district who said it beautifully
he said if you want this town to grow it
has to stink so a lot of us walked
around thinking yeah you know our
throats are Scratchy our eyes are a
little puffy but you know we're driving
nice cars and we put more stuff in our
houses so that's a trade-off that were
willing to make and the Earth Day
protests in the environment movement
said no absolutely not we're not gonna
tolerate that you have to stop polluting
the air and the skies and the land on
this planet that we live on so we've got
the EPA in 1970 we put real teeth in the
Clean Air Act in 1970 we passed the
Clean Water Act in 1972 and then you
know when I do my chef's kiss mwah it
what happened in 1990 when a bunch of
kind of libertarian conservative
economists and a bunch of tree huggers
got together and and put together a
cap-and-trade system for atmospheric
pollution and we've all kind of heard
about cap-and-trade the way it works is
the government sets the cap the maximum
amount of pollution you can allow and
then says to all the companies in these
polluting industries like electricity
generation you guys can go ahead and
trade with each other for the right to
pollute and that sounds deeply bizarre
right we don't want in pollution let
alone buying and selling the right to
pollute but the insight was spectacular
and it was that some emitters will have
an easier job reducing their emissions
and some will have a harder job what we
care about is the overall reduction in
the emissions we don't care if one is
comparatively dirty and one is
comparatively clean that's the second
order consideration we want that overall
cap to come down and the right way to
have the cap come down quickly is if we
allow the trading to happen because
markets are just great at finding out
who should be producing what including
pollution it turns out so cap and trade
for sulfur dioxide and lots of other
atmospheric pollutants has been this
ridiculous success over the past thirty
years in the country are at our
atmosphere is so much cleaner than it
was thirty years ago 50 years ago our
lungs are so much more healthy as a
result and the overall cost of reducing
those emissions is something like a
third or a fifth of the original
estimates so I'm intensely grateful to
the earth day protesters in the
environmental movement because they said
guys we're not gonna we're not gonna sit
here as voters as citizens and tolerate
the pollution then they helped come up
with really smart ways to make it go
down and then the other thing they did
was say we have to stop killing the
creatures that we shared the planet with
just this fundamental aspect of
stewardship right
don't kill the other creatures we were
failing that in a huge way we drove the
passenger pigeon extinct by 1914 this
was a bird in the 19th century that
flocked it in in groups so dense that
they could blot out the Sun right and we
made it extinct early in the 19th
century we damn near drove the North
American bison out of existence and over
the course of the 20th century we had
these industrial era ships and we went
after whales in all the oceans of the
world with this kind of wanton Glee and
we almost wiped out many many different
species of whale we did it not because
they had any magic ingredient that was
so rare we couldn't find it anyplace
else
we made margarine and lubricants out of
the world's whales I mean this this is a
crime right this is a moral crime and it
would have been compounded if we driven
more of these creatures extinct and so
the Earth Day movement said we're not
we're not gonna allow this we're not
going to tolerate this anymore
we had a whale moratorium which was
passed I believe in the
1970s most countries around the world
have signed up for it and you asked
earlier what I'm up to mystic about man
one of the things makes me really
optimistic is these things work and a
phrase that I first heard from Stuart
brand is nature bats last and if we can
just kind of get the hell out of the way
give the oceans back to the whales fence
off oceans and national parks and
seasons of the year from hunting and
exploitation these animals will come
back we once we drive on to extinction
we don't have the toolkit yet to bring
them back but wow if we can just leave
them alone and stop doing this wanton
destruction the species will come back
there are we believe that there were
about 500 individual blue whales left in
the world Southern Oceans in the early
1970s I think there are depending on
which estimate you believe between 10 or
20,000 or even more of these animals and
the more southern oceans right now then
we can win these battles and that's what
environmentalism taught me we have to
fight these battles and we have to win
these battles now after you know I can't
praise them enough for that but we have
to say a couple things I think that they
got long and one of them one aspect of
the environmental movement that I'm not
onboard with is the D growth wing of the
party or this notion that we have to
reduce not just the amount of stuff that
we have minimalism is fantastic but the
overall size of the economy that's the
only way that we're gonna be able to
take better care of the earth is if we
humans decide to renounce higher levels
of prosperity I you know higher levels
of income and the things that come along
with that I am NOT on board for that
for the really simple reason that I
don't think the evidence shows that D
growth is necessary America has not
embraced D growth over the past half a
century and we haven't outsourced all of
our pollution all of our environmental
devastation
however our footprint on the planet is
now going down even as growth continues
so I guess you know if we're trying to
hang a label on me I might be a
pro-growth minimalist as a way to say it
well I think I am too as long as it's
the right kind of growth right there are
two types of growth you I can go to the
gym and build a muscle and that that is
good growth I can also have get a tumor
and and that's cancerous tumors is a bad
growth and it sounds to me like
you're trying to delineate here is there
is such thing as good growth responsible
growth could maybe be another way to
yeah describe it and irresponsible
growth you let me pick up on that
because I think responsible is a
beautiful adjective here responsible
growth in in my world and what I learned
writing more from less responsible
growth entails two deeply important
things first of all we have to deal with
the bad side effect of growth of stuff
of generating an economy and the bad
side effect is pollution and so if we
grow and we let things stink and we let
the water get contaminated that is
deeply irresponsible growth but what I
think we have learned is how to have
growth that is responsible in that way
I'll say it again pollution levels are
down the air is so much cleaner the air
over London for example is much much
cleaner than it was in 1700 this just
blew my mind when I heard about it for
the first time and by the way if you
think I'm I'm not sorry if you don't
believe me you can read my book or go to
our world and data which is one of the
great websites that's ever been created
because it's exactly what it said just a
bunch of data and you can go
double-check almost all the claims that
I'm making here and there's a great
graph of that in the show notes yeah
yeah please do there's a great graph of
air pollution over London that I think
starts in 1700 and where it is right now
is so much lower we need to be clear
even before the Kovan recession kicked
in and the skies got so much cleaner
because we're not driving anywhere even
before then we're doing so much better
than we've been doing for hundreds of
years so the first aspect to me of
responsible growth is growth with lower
pollution over time the second aspect is
to say look there are some things that
we are not going to use as raw materials
to fuel our growth you know the process
of production is converting raw
materials into finished goods the idea
that Wales were an OK raw material to me
is D like wrong wrong wrong
let's not have endangered animals as as
inputs as raw materials for our
productive processes
let's not chop down vulnerable forests
if we have an alternative let's take
ecosystems and creatures and species and
put them
outside of this this relentless engine
of capitalism and markets that we have
and I will sit here in cheerlead all day
for capitalism and markets because I
think they make humanity more prosperous
and they solve our problems over time I
am never going to cheerlead for putting
whales into the capitalist system that's
just a mistake so if we can do these two
things if we can deal with the bad side
effects of growth which is primarily
pollution and we can we can call timeout
or call BS on having vulnerable
ecosystems and creatures be an input to
growth an input to production man if we
do both those things and that's really
important homework I kind of sit back
and get confident that we're going to do
the right thing by the planet you know
what I like about your book is you are
at times you're you're both pro market
and pro regulation these two things they
exactly it's almost as though there is a
a tension here but it's a necessary
tension it's a completely necessary
tension and and my view is not that
wacky actually if you go look at any
good econ 101 textbook and an econ 101
is a phrase that I use all the time to
describe people who have you know a
decent introductory grounding a solid
grounding in economics what you will
learn in your econ 101 textbook in the
first couple chapters is markets are
awesome right markets are the best
things that we humans have ever come up
with to produce goods and services and
get them to their and allocate them
correctly
not to say markets are perfect right
like I don't want to be come across as
some kind of fundamentalist but markets
are really good at producing and
allocating things about chapter you know
three or four in your econ 101 textbook
you switch over from extolling markets
to examining their failure modes and the
first one that you typically learn about
is an externality and in particular a
negative externality is the kind of
externality you don't want which is very
simply Josh if you and I decide to
engage in a transaction in most cases
the rest of the world doesn't care about
it if you and I engage in a transaction
that makes things worse for other people
somehow who are not part of that
transaction that's a negative
externality and I almost every good econ
101 textbook that I've come across
exhibit a of your negative
externality is pollution if you buy from
my factory but my factory pollutes than
the people in my neighborhood
whether or not they're buying my stuff
are suffering from it we can't we can't
deal with negative we can allow negative
externalities and here's the key point
markets left to their own devices
typically don't deal with them don't
solve them so this is when you know
every decent economists that I know
acknowledges a proper role for
government to deal with negative
externalities so that's why I the
libertarian label very often sits sits
uncomfortably with me I just have too
much of an awareness of negative
externalities and how bad they are and
how critically important they are to
deal with and as much as I love markets
I don't think they naturally do a good
job of dealing with pollution and
pollution and other negative
externalities we're seeing this right
now play out in real time as you
mentioned with this pandemic the air is
much cleaner I'm here in Los Angeles
right now and I've never ever seen it
even remotely close to this it's yeah
it's like I live in a different place
it's like I moved somewhere else it's
weird isn't it it is it's totally weird
but it to me this is the experiment this
is showing you right now that if we
innovate enough if we're 100% electric
cars at this point this is what an error
would look like right now that's right
that's right and so this is a really key
point because I was just talking about
the victories of the past half century
of the environmental movement the air in
LA
holy Toledo is it cleaner than it was in
1970 I mean before the pandemic kicked
in the air in LA was so much cleaner
than it was in 1970 we don't have killer
smaug's anymore we don't have Smuggler's
on the morning Drivetime radio anymore
however it's really important to say
this clearly pollution is still too high
and this is one of the things we're
learning with the pandemic is if when
all these internal combustion engines
leave the highways the air gets a lot
cleaner in Boston and LA and all these
different cities that tells me that we
have a we've come so far they've got a
long way to go still if we really want
to live on a cleaner earth and take
better care of us in our planet there's
a lot more work I think we know the path
ahead and like you just said it
to go through this energy transition to
electrify the fleet so that we're not
putting out all these particulates all
the time and in my view all that
electricity would be generated by
nuclear power plants all over the world
that's the utopian sci-fi future that I
want to live in well Mariah thank you so
much for your question I'm gonna send
you a copy of Andy's book more from les
I hope you find a lot of value in that
and I want to move on really quickly to
our lightning round now this is where we
answer our audiences text messages you
can text us your questions 937 2o 2 4 6
5 4 and those texts actually go straight
to Ryan's and my phones we answer as
many as we can we don't answer every
question but occasionally we answer them
on air here on the podcast now Andy
during the lightning round we do our
best to answer questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response finally we monitor on a bit and
then Shawn teases out something makes it
tweetable and beautiful in in post so
our question today is from Sol B so B
wants to know how do we rewire people's
brains so they don't impulsively buy
dumb stuff now this is obviously a
contributing factor Andy to a lot of
this is exactly what we were talking
about earlier irresponsible growth a lot
of that is us
corporations or even individuals touting
a message of more more MORE you are
incomplete and thus you need to purchase
my product or service and therefore you
will be complete as soon as you do that
now we've all tried this we've all
bought things to be happy and of course
in the moment we get the the momentary
burst of pleasure or dopamine but
long-term the the the pleasure fades and
in fact the object of our consumption
and enjoy becomes the object of our
discontent on a long enough timeline and
so my pithy answer is just minimize
carefully that which is essential for
the next person maybe non-essential for
you and I think that's that we want to
keep that in mind as well we we see
these advertisements for the thing the
the widget the car the shirt whatever
and it looks appropriate on the
mannequin
or in the advertisement but the question
is is that appropriate for you and and I
wonder how you would address the B's
question here I mean of course we can
have regulations but I don't want to
judge people and say you shouldn't buy
this this know certain anything yes
you're not I you and your in your book
in fact you you you were sort of against
central planning especially government
central plan deeply very lonely again I
should actually that's not the adverb
you should use it in this day and age
central planning I'm not virus-like
about anything well let's let's talk
about this question let's maybe dive a
little bit a little bit deeper here we
don't want to stop people from from
buying stuff quite often we want to open
their eyes and that's the difference
between I think minimalism
I don't think of minimalism as an
ideology some yeah no no absolutely not
and in fact you know in and it's not
even you know stoicism which I think
vert lines aligns quite closely to to
minimalism
it's almost stoicism for your stuff in a
way yeah there you go
and and I have a friend who wrote a book
called stuffication
you know we've all been suffocated by it
by our stuff and and and so now here we
are yes where a lot of us are
impulsively buying dumb stuff and I can
only say that because I am a a former
order myself I had the big suburban
house with over three hundred thousand
items in it and and at some point I
realized I wasn't going to get the joy
from it and so I'm not proselytizing
what I'm trying to do is share a recipe
and I get that from your book as well
you're not making a specific
prescription here are the hundred things
you must do but there are some
observations and then allowing people to
make decisions on their own so let me
give a really short answer to this
excellent question and then a little bit
longer one my short answer is just
repeat the mantra stuff does not make
you happy
and Josh I know that's your whole reason
for setting this up and for getting
these ideas out there into the world we
just need to keep repeating it to
ourselves and at that moment of purchase
and we're going for that
if that mantra kicks in no actually
stuff does not make us happy and the
more often I repeat that to myself the
more it sinks in now let me give you a
little bit longer answer to that
question which is the answer that I
learned from Danny Kahneman who's just
you know is he's a living legend
yeah he's the first non economist to win
the nobel prize in economics who's a
psychologist by training and I've met
Danny I've talked to him a couple of
times he's just this like he's like Yoda
he's just this deeply wise thoughtful
guy the forces like is super with Danny
Kahneman and we invited him to one of
our conferences and my co-author Erik
Brynjolfsson was interviewing him on
stage and he said Danny I know you've
been doing some happiness research what
can you tell us about it and Kahneman
said when I was a kid or a young man in
Israel we got air conditioning for the
very first time which like you can
imagine it's a big deal in Israel right
and condiments ed went man when that
when that a/c unit
kicked on for the first time it was like
that like the skies had parted in heaven
had opened up and it was just the most
amazing feeling of not sweltering in you
know summer in Israel and he said it
made me deeply happy and then he said
does hair conditioning still make me
deeply happy
look no I'm glad I'm not sweltering but
do I break out in this crazy smile like
I did the first time the AC unit kicked
on he's like no and so I'm in the
audience thinking he's just telling us a
story about how we get accustomed to
things and were constantly you know
we're wired to want more and happiness
is elusive and all that and I was kind
of like yeah I get it but
it's kind of a bummer and the condiment
said now think about your Friday evening
poker game he said you can have that
Friday evening poker game for 30 years
with the same group of friends and you
will look forward to the Friday evening
poker game in the 30th year as much as
you did during the first year and I'm
sitting in the audience it was like
somebody had dropped a brick on my head
of knowledge and I'm like that is
actually completely correct because when
I think about the times that I look
forward to in a the shopping trip it's
it's not
you know clicking on the the purchase
button it's oh man I've got some friends
coming over got these I got new friends
and old friends I got this crowd that
I'm into and we're just gonna hang out
we're gonna go do something like that
man happiness is the right word for that
feeling so what what what condiment
taught me you know the mantra is stuff
doesn't make you happy
repeated social engagements with your
friends that does make you happy go do
that right right and and I think that
you know if I just talked to a stoic
philosopher who was on the podcast and
he his name's William Irvine and he's
written some really great books on on
stoicism and and what I learned is that
you know you drop the stoic into from
you know 2500 years ago or whatever you
drop them into 20 20 even amid the the
pandemic that they would be so amazed
and they would look around as so many
people who are so discontented and and
and say oh wow Yee you're you're a
really troubled person if you're not
able to be contented with all of this
you know sort of progress and and all of
the all of the benefits of modern life
then maybe you're telling yourself the
wrong story and I think that story is
that we're constantly pursuing things to
make us happy and what you're
illustrating there is that our
experiences have a much better return on
investment than buying the next widget
in a particular category of experience
there are several categories of
experience that that will bring you that
deep happiness one of them is again it's
the Friday night poker game it's dinner
parties with your friends it's going for
a walk together we humans are such an
intensely social species that we almost
forget that it's almost it it goes
beneath the surface but we're the most
intensely social species in many ways on
the planet and cutting ourselves off
from that it's really easy to do because
there's there are screens there are
things we're super busy we've got jobs
all kinds of reasons not to do that
stuff man prioritizing that like having
a group of friends investing in them
spending time with them just hanging out
that may if that that's one of the show
I can think of to be happier yeah you're
reminding me of a one of my favorite
jokes from a comedy special recently
Ronny Chang has this great comedy
special and one of his bits is it when I
came to America it seemed like Americans
were having a competition to see how
many screens they could get between
their face and the wall and it's so true
I mean I see it all the time and I am I
am myself a a victim with him not being
intentional you've got the TV on the
wall and the iPhone in the hand and you
know the Kindle or the tablet or the
people have the Apple watch and
everything else is like right there and
I'm pacifying myself but that's not
happiness pacification is is is
different yeah I will I will defend
technology all day every day I write
books about it I've devoted my career to
trying to understand where this tech is
taking us and in general I think it's
taking us to a better place I really
really do but you bring up something
these screens these devices are
incredibly powerful things and they have
improved humanity and if you don't
believe that go to a part of the world
that doesn't have even basic ability to
communicate or share knowledge or see
what the world is up to and then watch
what happens when they get these phones
get smartphones for the first time
there's not a dry eye in the house right
so I will defend these things all day
every day
however they are designed to be
addictive it's not paper over that right
that's what these things do and okay so
is an Oreo cookie so is a hot fudge
sundae so as heroin lots of things are
designed to be addictive our homework is
not to just never eat I'm not advocating
heroin right go have a phone go have an
Apple watch go do these things and don't
deny them to other people however you're
just dealing with another addictive
device part of our homework is thinking
people is to rise above that and and not
not just like pacify not just B be a
recipient and I and passive recipient of
what these screens what these devices
want us to do so
one of the most helpful things that I've
done is when I first get up in the
morning I have a no screens for
15-minute rule and I drink my espresso
and I kind of walk around and stretch
and do stuff like that and I find that's
really helpful because if I don't do
that I'm looking at the screen you know
thirty seconds after I wake up in the
morning and I think that's a bad way to
go again as much as I love these devices
in these technologies all right before
we get into our added value segment and
our listener tips today it looks like we
got a bunch more surprise questions this
week our smart phones bad for the planet
who's to blame for the environmental
degradation we are currently
experiencing even if the u.s. stops
polluting China and India won't so
what's the solution
will the kovat 19 pandemic significantly
slow our consumption of unnecessary junk
why is the economy based on how much
money we spend and what is a good
alternative and also is recycling
actually making a difference at all or
is it merely perceived as a responsible
decision for the environment
I think his answer enters answer on that
is going to surprise you it really
surprises me I know he's written about
the topic and I'm still having some
cognitive dissidence even thinking about
it right now we're also going to talk
about ubi yeah universal basic income
versus a negative income tax as
potential solutions for our country
plus a bunch more questions for Andrew
and if you wanna hear all that listen to
this week's maximal episode on the
minimalist private podcast that's right
you're currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
and our guests we record an entirely
different much longer maximal episode on
the minimalist private podcast it's just
two bucks and it's the most honest way
for this podcast to earn an income
because we don't believe in
advertisements you know we think
advertisements suck so we make money
only if you find value in and if you
support the things that we create by the
way when you subscribe to the minimalist
private podcast you'll receive a
personal link so that our maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app that link also grants you access to
our entire back catalogue of hundreds of
private podcast episodes find all the
details over at the minimalists com
support also right now on that private
podcast you can check out 40 quarantine
conversations that Ryan and I have had
we've been calling up friends and
friends of the podcast and asking them
how they're coping with and how some of
them are even thriving during these
trying times these conversations have
been illuminating and you can check
those out right now the minimalists comm
slash support to become a supporter and
get access to that private podcast all
right now check out some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners hey
Josh and Ryan this is Andy from Portland
Oregon I wanted to call to give you guys
a packing tip so I have done a lot of
traveling in my life
ace to travel for work four to five days
a week and since then now I just travel
for fun usually but one of the best
things that I came across to really
minimize what I travel with is to pack
in advance to try to pack for my trip a
couple days and really lay out my
outfits for each day see what items I
can mix and match then I put it all in
the suitcase and I wait and then two
days before the trip I'll go in and say
what can I remove what do I not think
that I'll need I find that when I
revisit my outfits or my planning that
it's easier for me to take out a couple
excess items I like to consider myself
somewhat fashionable so whether it's a
bag or a pair of shoes or shirt I
usually find that I can take out one or
two items this is allowed me to go to
China and Russia for three weeks both
for fun and for work all in a carry-on
hi this is Tracy from New Jersey and I'm
responding to Amy's dilemma with the
pictures that she had from the passing
of her father this happened to us a few
years ago when my husband's parents both
died within a short span of each other
and we took all of the pictures from
their home in order to try to organize
them for the family what worked really
well for us is I went through the
pictures instead of
because I was more dispassionate about
it the pictures didn't hold a lot of
memories for me and I think he would
have agonized over each and every photo
the first thing I did is I separated any
photo that didn't have people in it and
I got rid of them my in-laws loved
taking pictures of landscapes and
flowers and birds and they were
beautiful but they had no meaning to us
at all I'm sure they gave hid my in-laws
great pleasure but they didn't hold any
meaning for us so those immediately went
the pictures that were left had people
in them and I sat down with my husband
and I said identify the people so I can
write it on the back and if he didn't
know who the people were the picture
went it obviously again held no meaning
for him there were a few that we reached
out to his siblings and said do you know
these people are and if we could
identify them it went into the keep pile
then finally we went to the keep pile
and we looked for things that were
similar if there were 10 pictures from a
party nine of them probably went and
doing this over a period of about two
weeks we whittled the pictures down
about 95% and the ones that were left
we scanned and we made an album a
digital album and we gave a copy to each
of our siblings this worked really well
it brought up a lot of nice memories and
it saved my husband the agony of going
through each and every picture alright
Joe thanks again to Andrew McAfee for
joining us today check out his new book
more from less we'll put a link to that
in the show notes and real quick four
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalist I want to encourage you to
check out our YouTube channel we have
Jordan no more our filmmaker is creating
some beautiful videos over at
youtube.com slash the minimalists not
only did we just finish up season three
of living room conversations so there's
60 episodes now of living room
conversations and season three has been
one of my favorites so far you can check
those out you can also check out
unpacking minimalism the first three
episodes of unpacking minimalism where
Jordan takes a topic that we discussed
on the podcast briefly and he unpacked
he talks to a bunch of people about that
topic gets different perspective
different different perspectives and
creates these little mini documentaries
about each topic so so far we've covered
the wallet a minimalist wallet we've
covered the car and our obsession with
khaliqul car culture and we've also
dived into joy the joy is the title of
that episode and also we are starting a
new series it's called let's talk about
less it's a video essay series where I
unpack a particular topic in an essay so
maybe I'm talking about the economy or
maybe I'm talking about minimalism in
general or maybe I'm talking about
problems with the internet and trying to
show the minimalist approach the
minimalist solution to some of the
problems we have in modern day life
that's called let's talk about let's
talk about less and it is now available
on our YouTube channel youtube.com slash
the minimalist now you can follow the
minimalist on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram at the minimalist if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists com if you
want our show notes in your inbox sign
up for our email list at the minimalists
comm and you'll also receive our simple
Sunday emails now for our added value
this week let's listen to at the door
from the new abnormal it's the new album
from The Strokes and really I think it's
the the perfect description for the
times in which we are living the new
abnormal and if you leave here today
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for listen
y'all we'll see you next time
and minimus